Das muss man sich mal vorstellen: Sie strahlen
im sichtbaren Licht mit einer Leuchtkraft,
die bis zu 1014 (10 hoch 14 ) mal größer
ist als die der Sonne!
Das ist 100 Billionen Mal heller!
Kaum zu verstehen.
Wow”!
Die Rede ist von Quasaren.
Das sind die Zentren von aktiven Galaxien
und bis heutzutage haben wir mehrere tausend
solcher Quasare entdeckt.
Sie sind die hellsten bekannten Objekte in
unserem Kosmos.
Und das paradoxe: Es sind Schwarze Löcher.
Moment Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt
es täglich spannende Science-Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal.
Nur dann verpasst ihr kein Video. herzlich
willkommen
und vielen Dank für Euren Themenvorschlag,
den ihr mir über Whats App geschickt habt!
Den Link zu WhatsApp findet ihr in der Videobeschreibung.
1960 hatten Forschungsteams rätselhafte Radioquellen
am HImmel aufgespürt, die genau wie Sterne
Radiowellen ins All schicken.
Doch es konnte sich nicht um Sterne handeln,
denn dafür waren sie viel zu weit weg.
Das, was die Signale aussandte, war also entweder
extrem lichtschwach oder aber unsichtbar.
1962 hatte man dann bessere Instrumente am
Start und den Forschungsteams gelang es doch,
etwas zu erkennen: Also doch schwach leuchtende
Sterne?
Jedenfalls unvorstellbar weit weg von uns
- das Licht hatte mehrere Milliarden Jahre
zu unserer Erde gebraucht.
Und so konnte es sich eigentlich nicht um
einen Stern handeln, denn diesen hätte man
aus solch einer Entfernung gar nicht sehen
können.
Ein riesiges Rätsel für Astronominnen und
Astronomen weltweit!
Die große Frage also: Was steckte wirklich
hinter diesen mysteriösen Objekten?!
Fest stand zumindest schon mal ihr Name: Getauft
hatte man die kosmischen Objekte “Quasar”
- abgeleitet von quasistellar.
Es braucht noch einige Zeit, bis bessere Teleskope
entwickelt worden waren, die dann endlich
die Auflösung des Rätsels mit sich brachten:
Quasare sind die Kerne von Galaxien, die besonders
viel Radiostrahlung aussenden!
Konkret gesagt sind Quasare die Kerne von
AKTIVEN Galaxien - anders als unsere Milchstraße,
die so gut wie gar nicht aktiv ist.
Erst ganze 36 Jahre später konnte eine Wirtsgalaxie
der Quasare fotografiert werden.
Das gelang dem Weltramteleskop “Hubble”
und machte somit noch einmal deutlicher, dass
es sich bei den kosmischen Objekten um die
hellen Kerne von Galaxien handelt.
Theoretische Physikerinnen und Physiker erkannten
schnell, dass die unfassbare Leuchtkraft der
Quasare NICHT mit der thermonuklearen Fusion
- wie sie im Sternen-Inneren abläuft - zu
erklären ist.
Stattdessen sorgen Schwarze Löcher dafür,
dass Quasare heller leuchten als Milliarden
von Sterne.
Diese sitzen in der der Mitte von großen
Galaxien und sind suppermassereich - etwa
so schwer wie ein paar Millionen Sterne.
Doch das alleine erzeugt noch nicht die unfassbare
Leuchtkraft der Quasare, sondern erst ihre
Kombination mit großen Gaswolken.
Zu finden sind diese überall in einer Galaxie;
besonders gehäuft aber tatsächlich in ihren
Zentren.
Wenn sich solch eine Gaswolke dann einem Schwarzen
Loch nähert, bewegt es sich zunächst um
dieses herum.
In spiralförmigen Bahnen wandern die Gasteilchen
immer weiter auf das Loch zu und fallen irgendwann
hinein.
Eine Scheibe aus Staub und Gas umgibt also
das Schwarze Loch und leuchtet dabei extrem
hell.
Die Akkretionsscheibe.
Dafür sorgen zwei Phänomene: Zum einen die
die Wechselwirkung der Teilchen mit dem Magnetfeld
des Schwarzen Loch und zum anderen die ganze
Energie, die die Teilchen auf ihren Spiralbahnen
verlieren und so ins All abgegeben.
Und so leuchtet die Scheibe um das Schwarze
Loch extrem hell, obwohl es selbst kein Licht
abgibt.
Nicht das komplette Gas wird in das Schwarze
Loch gesogen.
Zwei große Ströme werden entlang der Magnetfeldlinien
ins All geschleudert - und zwar mit sehr hoher
Geschwindigkeit.
Diese sogenannten Jets können unvorstellbare
Millionen Lichtjahre lang sein.
Das ist auch die Erklärung dafür, dass sehr
aktive Galaxien mit starken Quasaren in ihren
Zentren weniger Sterne hervorbringen.
Schließlich ist dafür nach einiger Zeit
nicht mehr genug von dem benötigten Gas vorhanden.
Im vergangenen Jahr (2017) hat ein US-Forschungsteam
übrigens den bislang entferntesten Quasar
überhaupt entdeckt: Sein Licht benötigt
mehr als 13 Milliarden bis zur Erde.
In dem Galaxiekern befindet sich ein Schwarzes
Loch mit 800 Millionen Sonnenmassen.
Dieser Fund liefert der Fachwelt viele spannende
Informationen zu der frühen Geschichte unseres
Universums.
Denn ihr wisst ja: Seit dem Urknall vor 13,79
Milliarden Jahren dehnt sich das Universum
aus - und damit natürlich auch das Licht,
das von solchen weit entfernten Objekten zur
Erde kommt.
Physikalisch gesehen verschiebt sich die Wellenlänge
des Licht damit - und zwar in den roten Bereich.
Somit können Experten berechnen, wie lange
das Licht gebraucht hat, um die Erde zu erreichen.
Bei diesem weit entfernten Quasar waren es
wohl 13,1 Milliarden Jahre - das entspricht
einer Rotverschiebung von 7,54.
Ziemlich krass also: Denn die Aufnahmen des
Galaxiekerns zeigen ihn somit also so, wie
er 690 Millionen Jahre nach dem Urknall ausgesehen
hat.
Ein super spannender Blick in die Vergangenheit
also!
Und nicht nur das - Quasare sind auch enorm
praktisch für uns.
Im “International Celestial Reference System”,
einem Koordinatensystem für Sterne und Planeten,
werden sie als Referenzpunkte genutzt.
Denn sie sind nicht nur enorm hell und gut
zu sehen, sondern scheinen sich von der Erde
aus gesehen kaum zu bewegen.
Natürlich bewegen sie sich, doch wir bekommen
hier aufgrund ihrer Entfernung kaum etwas
davon mit.
Wow.
Es gibt schon irre Phänomene da draußen.
Und wir berichten hier täglich darüber.
Wenn ihr kein Video zu diesen und allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt, dann abonniert Clixoom
auch auf englisch.
Denn auch da gibt es immer wieder Videopremieren.
Dafür einfach hier draufklicken.
Und hier geht es weiter mit: Exciting Discovery:
Monster Galaxy has more stars than the Milky
Way!
Bis bald hoffentlich auch auf dem englischen
Kanal.
See you soon, stay tuned!